MemodoAI hat gerade ein Update bekommen.
In den nächsten Minuten schauen wir uns an, was neu ist.
Die Kernaussage: MemodoAI kann jetzt mit deinem Microsoft 365 arbeiten.
Dazu wiederverwendbare Skills, Chat-Projekte und eine Handvoll praktischer Verbesserungen.
Alles, was du schon kennst, funktioniert weiterhin genau gleich.
Die größte Neuerung: MemodoAI kann jetzt dein eigenes Microsoft 365 lesen.
Deine Outlook-Mails, deinen Kalender, OneDrive- und SharePoint-Dateien, Excel, OneNote, Aufgaben
und Kontakte – direkt im Chat.
Das funktioniert über einen sogenannten MCP-Server.
Stell ihn dir als Konnektor vor, mit dem der Assistent für dich auf ein externes System
zugreifen kann.
Du aktivierst ihn im Composer, klickst auf „MCP Servers" und setzt bei „Microsoft 365 Aligned" ein Häkchen.
Ein kurzer Hinweis zur Verbindung.
Wenn du neben Microsoft 365 einen grünen Punkt siehst, ist sie aktiv.
Ist sie getrennt – was passieren kann, wenn deine Sitzung abläuft –,
klicke auf das kleine Stecker-Symbol und dann auf „Initialisieren".
Ein paar Sekunden später springt sie auf „Aktiv", und alles passt.
Jetzt stelle ich eine einfache Frage.
Über Microsoft 365 – wie lauten mein Anzeigename und meine Position?
Achte auf die Zeile unter der Antwort.
„get current user" in Microsoft 365 ausgeführt.
Sie zeigt dir genau, welches Tool verwendet wurde.
Du kannst darauf klicken, um mehr zu sehen.
Drei Dinge, die du im Hinterkopf behalten solltest.
Erstens: Es agiert als du.
Es nutzt deine eigene Microsoft-Anmeldung,
kann also immer nur das sehen, was du ohnehin sehen könntest.
Zweitens: Es kann vorerst nur lesen.
Es kann deine Mails und Dateien lesen,
aber es sendet, bearbeitet oder löscht nichts.
Und drittens: Nenne ein konkretes Ziel.
„Finde den ACME-Vertrag in SharePoint"
funktioniert deutlich besser als „Finde meine wichtigen Dokumente".
Alles, was es zurückliest, durchläuft weiterhin
dieselben Prüfungen für personenbezogene Daten wie der Rest von MemodoAI.
Die zweite große Neuerung sind Skills.
Ein Skill ist ein kleines, wiederverwendbares Playbook –
eine Anleitung dafür, wie du eine wiederkehrende Aufgabe erledigst,
die der Assistent nur dann heranzieht, wenn sie relevant ist,
statt dass du jedes Mal dieselben Vorgaben neu eintippst.
Das Clevere daran: MemodoAI kennt immer
den Namen und die einzeilige Beschreibung eines Skills,
lädt aber die vollständige Anleitung erst dann,
wenn eine Aufgabe tatsächlich dazu passt.
So kann der Assistent praktisch
eine ganze Bibliothek von Abläufen kennen,
ohne sie alle in jedem Gespräch mitzuführen.
Es gibt zwei Wege, einen zu nutzen.
Du kannst den Assistenten einfach selbst wählen lassen.
Ein aktivierter Skill greift automatisch,
wenn deine Anfrage zu seiner Beschreibung passt,
oder du rufst ihn per Namen auf.
Tippe ein Dollarzeichen ins Nachrichtenfeld,
und eine Auswahl listet deine Skills auf.
Ich wähle „Meeting-Notizen"
und füge ein grobes Team-Sync-Protokoll ein.
Sieh dir das Ergebnis an.
Der Assistent hat meine unordentlichen Notizen umgeformt –
in klare Abschnitte: Teilnehmende, Entscheidungen, To-dos mit Verantwortlichen und Fristen
und offene
Fragen. Diese Struktur kam vom Skill, nicht daher, dass ich danach gefragt habe. Du
verwaltest Skills im
Skills-Panel in der linken Leiste. Dort erstellst, bearbeitest und organisierst du sie. Um
einen anzulegen,
klicke auf das Plus und wähle „Skill-Anweisungen schreiben". Gib ihm einen Namen, eine Beschreibung,
die genau angibt,
wann er gelten soll, und die Anweisungen selbst in Markdown. Ein Muster,
das gut funktioniert –
übernommen von den schon vorhandenen Skills – sind drei Überschriften: Wann zu verwenden, Vorgehen
und Ausgabeformat. Speichere ihn, und er ist in deiner Bibliothek. Noch eine Sache, die du wissen solltest.
Skills
sind versioniert und lassen sich teilen, sodass ein Team eine verlässliche Sammlung von Playbooks aufbauen kann.
Korrigiere einen Ablauf
einmal, und alle, die ihn nutzen, bekommen die Korrektur. Zwei weitere Funktionen kamen mit diesem
Update. Die erste ist
für alle, die Agents bauen: Chaining. Im Agent-Builder unter „Erweitert" gibt es
einen Bereich für Multi-Agent-
Orchestrierung mit einer Chain-Option. Damit kannst du eine feste Abfolge von
Agents nacheinander
ausführen. Die Ausgabe des einen speist den nächsten. Hier siehst du eine Chain, in der ein primärer
Agent
an einen Uppercase-Bot übergibt, der dessen Ausgabe umwandelt. Das lohnt sich, wenn eine
Aufgabe
wirklich eigenständige Schritte hat. Denk aber daran: Jeder Schritt kostet Tokens und Zeit, daher brauchen die meisten
alltäglichen Aufgaben
das nicht. Die zweite ist Memory – und die ist für alle. MemodoAI kann sich jetzt
aktiv
Dinge merken, die du ihm sagst. Pass auf. Ich sage: Merke dir ab jetzt, dass ich im
Frontend-Team bin
und knappe, stichpunktartige Antworten bevorzuge.
Der Assistent bestätigt direkt in seiner Antwort,
was er gespeichert hat.
Diese Einträge stehen jetzt in deinem Memories-Panel,
dem Gehirn-Symbol in der linken Leiste,
wo du sie lesen, bearbeiten oder löschen kannst.
Es ist nur mit deinem Konto verknüpft,
und es gibt einen Schalter, um es jederzeit auszuschalten.
Es gibt nichts einzurichten.
Es funktioniert einfach, wo immer du chattest.
Wenn dein Chat-Verlauf lang wird,
helfen dir Projekte.
Du kannst jetzt zusammengehörige Unterhaltungen
in Projektordnern gruppieren, die oben in der Seitenleiste erscheinen.
Klicke auf „Neues Projekt", gib ihm einen Namen,
und du hast einen festen Ort, zum Beispiel für all deine Q3-Planungs-Chats.
Stell dir Projekte als Ordner vor, die Unterhaltungen gruppieren,
während Lesezeichen, die du bereits hast,
Tags sind, die du quer darüber hinweg vergibst.
Ein paar kleinere Verbesserungen, die dir bei der Arbeit auffallen werden.
Es gibt eine neue Kontextanzeige,
den kleinen Kreis in der Nachrichtenleiste.
Fahre mit der Maus darüber, und du siehst, wie voll
das Kontextfenster des Modells im aktuellen Chat ist. Es ist eine Auslastungsanzeige, keine Rechnung.
Sie zeigt,
wie viel Platz noch bleibt, nicht die Kosten. Wenn ein langer Chat sich zu füllen beginnt, ist das ein
guter Moment, um
einen neuen zu starten. Auch Office-Dateien sehen besser aus. Wenn du ein Word-Dokument, eine
Tabelle,
eine Präsentation oder eine CSV anhängst, erscheint sie jetzt als richtige Vorschaukarte statt als schlichter
Download-Link.
Und ein paar Kleinigkeiten. Neue Unterhaltungen bekommen sofort einen Titel, statt erst
nach der
ersten Antwort, und wenn du über eine Nachricht fährst, siehst du, wann sie gesendet wurde. Das war's Neue.
Wenn du
eine Auffrischung der Grundlagen möchtest – Modellauswahl, Dateisuche, Agents bauen –, deckt der
Haupt-Getting-Started-
Guide all das ab, und nichts davon hat sich geändert. Danke fürs Zuschauen.